a big part of the brazilian jiu-jitsu
was created by my father
exactly because my uncle carlos learned
from
maeda from from condi coma
and maeda was a champion
he's been fighting for all over and and
went to brazil to settle
and he started teaching uncle carlos
based on the friendship he has with my
grandfather and in that process
uncle chucalus learned a lot from from
aydah but
elio was 12 years younger than my
my uncle and was very
very young kid at this time and then
they went to rio
in 1925 cerro in rio
and my uncle carlos opened his first
school in 1925.
at this point my father was
could not do any sports he was doctor
said for him
to not do anything not playing soccer
not ride a bike not skate nothing
because
he's very skinny and he has vertical all
the time
so he's pass out any any effort he's
passing out so he
had to rest so my uncle opened this
school
my my father's sitting on the corner all
the time watching my uncle teach
and for three years from 13 years old to
he was just watching amazed watching all
the details all the says all the
moves but he never practiced and one day
a student arrived at the school and my
uncle was not there yet
so my father said mister if you wanna do
let's play a little b until my brother
arrive
so with that they start to practice half
hour later my uncle arrived
and the student said carlos if you don't
mind i like to keep training with the
kid because he's so
good i love to practice with him so and
that's the way
my father get into jiu-jitsu practice
but different than a normal person my
father could not do
one pull-up one pull-up or one push-up
he don't have the strength in the
muscles to do that
so he basically a choke for example
which is a
he learned as an arm movement where to
grab the collars and squeeze the guy to
choke
he could not even think about choke
somebody with the
strength on his arms so he has to bring
together and use the
chest which trans which
transforms the whole pressure on the
choke giving less
effort muscularly and much more
efficiency technically
so that's just a very simple example of
how my dad in every movement he could do
he adapt for him
weak for his own weakness and he's
another very important element is
he was so light and so small he could
not ever fight on top
mount positions passing guards and and
and kick-ass
kick-ass from the top so he was able
to just stay on the bottom regardless
and he was able
to create from the guard position as
such a
new arsenal of tricks because he has
nothing to do but
guard so he developed a guard
in a very elegant style in a brazilian
style which
doesn't belong to japan at all all the
ground techniques from the bottom are
developed by
by my father which is weak enough should
not do other things
so he's improving we normally say in in
the family
elio gracias for jiu-jitsu as einstein
is to physics
he's a creator he's a genius is
impossible to compare
and follow this this idea of of
of total connection with the techniques
and the development
the jiu-jitsu the brazilian jiu-jitsu
becomes more like
effective in the valley tudo and the
no holds bar and effectiveness overall
with ghee without ghee
because gives to the weaker one elements
to
to submit the bigger one so i felt like
jujitsu really becomes
a a art for a weaker one
after passed through through
brazil before
condi coma con de mayo de como was a
very effective he has
many many victories but he was a stock
guy
he was solid strong japanese
not too tall but it was very solid maybe
80 kilos or 85 kilos or something so
he was dealing jiu-jitsu in his own form
of athleticism
which is different than what my dad
implies so
we are very grateful to have eddie
gracie and the family to to bring
another possibilities for our
style yeah that's um
it seems like in jiu jitsu when when you
have
jiu jitsu like that it's the situation
where like you said somebody that's
smaller and weaker
can defeat someone that's bigger and
stronger and everybody that starts
jiu-jitsu for the first time when i
started jiu-jitsu for the first time
you know i was like i said i was 220
pounds uh my first teacher was fabio
santos
i think he weighs i don't know 150 160
pounds
he would just do whatever he wanted to
me
and he was an old man at the time he was
probably younger than i am right now but
he seemed like he was an old man i said
how's this old man with gray hair
going to do anything to me and jiu-jitsu
allows you to do that
jiu-jitsu is you know what what your dad
because he had
like you said because he was smaller
because he was weaker he had to develop
that style
and it's so effective yes
leverage replaces strength you know
techniques replace the speed so
when you have the perfect combination
you can anticipate the movement you can
use timing at your favor
and other deflections so it's a very
interesting concept of
uh winning without really banging heads
to head you have to make
like set him up or or fake or
set up in a way to to almost surprise
the guy with in
and defeat not exactly smash him you
know
it's too brutal sometimes it's too much
to
boost fighting you know i love to see
the
the articulation of a technician
suppress
the strength so for me i was amazed
about the effects of
and the possibilities of jiu-jitsu